[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich war
[Musik]
so
zusammen
die neuigkeiten zu haben
franken
dass ich es ohne lassen sodass
ich habe ne riesige angst
für mich ist nicht wie ich wird der welt
[Musik]
das onyx
trug und in münster am vormittag als
pizzabote mit nine eleven und war es das
mit uns
am liebsten dank turbo steht winter-
oder falten oder
nein erleben nicht immer noch top thema
in der schweizer familie wo in mallorcas
miterlebt hat und jetzt aber ruhig haben
die zentralredaktion des
frieses dient sie sind recht
ambitionierten der quelle muss eine
recht groß sein wie gebiet alles schätze
m3 in seinen dicken machen jeden tag
mein leben ist natürlich groß
schwierig sie noch den mal eine news
verzählt sie sind haben wir ja das thema
zu regional das hätte ich nie
irgendetwas der region wo dazuverdienen
für die natürlich
okay
was macht ein foto wusste kann tanzen
unter anderem bietet zur pädagogischen
hochschule zentralschweiz
morgen lebe der pflichtstoff kann ich da
nur sagen wer übernimmt das sich absolut
nicht
[Musik]
bloß
eine playlist kümmern
also
heißt
dann stehen wir uns nur bis mittags im
fond und
[Musik]
retouren weniger genau
also zur polit szene ist sehr lebendig
sie
starke auseinandersetzungen natürlich
aufgrund ein stück paradies rohstoff
handelsplatzes
politische klima ist relativ hätte sie
aber gleichzeitig ist der menschliche
kontakt stark sie zum beispiel als
kantonsrätinnen und kantonsräte sind wir
immer mit einer gasse und dort ist es
eigentlich dass der bug sieht das bottai
mäßig zusammensetzt ich bin meistens mit
denen sie accessoires
user sehen darüber schwingen und das
sind ja eher die konservative
[Musik]
rücksicht nun konnte unsere dienen
konnte kein zocker sogar meistens
familie die auch könige von denen kommt
unsere es ist sehr sans verhältnis zu
den parlamentariern
es galt die gäste bewiesen
sie kontrollieren
nein mit energie
als kunde
mit asche in der atlantic das ist
wichtig
da ich muss mir völlig offen
ok danke
das wünschte ihnen haben
[Musik]
also ich bin erstaunt dass firefox vom
kant und zog mädchen für alles was habe
ich damit seid also im kantonsrat
peter gasser stellen stellen den augen
das liegt vor allem journalisten
manuskripte woche herren sehr an sie
wende prompt ich zurück sein und ich
haben können oder
dringlichkeit ist sie angst
gewachsen
und habe ihnen schon gerichte
arbeitsplatz zwar nur platz kam bremen
[Musik]
steckt dennoch nicht wissen
und provisorische angeschafften
ausschuss
blasen
aber im 27
september
konto unserer ca also wunderbar taxis
ohne meine hand kaffeepause auch nach
hinten geschoben ist auf die 412 ihn und
war mit einem haushalt 22 francos mieter
kasse und nachmittag waren erste frau
dadou und ich waren
herzlich begrüßt wurde also es war ein
schöner tag oder war
[Musik]
klage strom
cool
passiere
[Musik]
ich mag mich noch gut erinnern
sich am morgen zwei starke traktanden
griffen die schulentwicklung und
vergabe vortrag
darauf wahrscheinlich sie wie immer ich
bin in der zweiten reihe kasse und
hinter mir ist der nur als sie mit cvp
kantonsrat
und dann hat nur der anbieter nach wie
kann so laut und hatte dadurch platz das
stimmt doch für mich oder so man ist ja
eigentlich locker und ruft sie
[Musik]
im oberen stock
europa
damit die grabplatte und hatten den
geschnitten und telefoniert
[Applaus]
haben uns wenig steckdose
hamburgische hochschulen schulen
erfahren dass man immer denkt okay
[Musik]
gut und ich frage antwort okay
gefühle aber
stets beliebte könnte unsere emotionen
wie veli kavlak und tanju sie von
vorteil und dann bekommt und zug
danke
[Musik]
die letzte 2 lytro gerät handhaben
erinnere bevor denn die katastrophe
passiert ist dass ich als kantonsrat der
martin darüber lag sie um das
regierungsrates schon pro flasche und
beide an das paar minuten später klappt
[Musik]
bevor die zeit
okay gut
ob sie dem 1 1 gesagt haben bezahlt und
sind daher auch vor der vereidigung von
jungen absolventen sie mit der
vorbereitung
die canon eos politiker sind sagen
verständlicherweise auge isst mit
antworten endlager oder sind gar nicht
oft mag das heißt eine schutzweste
himmel das ist einzig um eine 3ten diese
waffen sind entlade gesprächen mit
einer jacke macht richtig gut
ja da waren familien
die vereidigung von jungen absolventen
und dem konto und logisches eben die
ganzen schönen anlass sieht es im
nordirak würdige nie gesehen und den
hens noch eine zeige wie man anfangs 50
machten heute gemachten
personenkontrollen und so wieder mehr
entdeckt es mit seiner festnahme war zum
ok go
[Musik]
was sie noch gut weiß ich dass es ein
telefon haben besser macht man einfach
das handy der bild klar dass heise ich
haben wie sie aus dem kantonsrat user
wie in unserer stock des kommissions-
zimmer und hanna führen für ihren
vorstoß oder für ihre reden müsse
telefonische abklärungen machen wie wir
stehen
also im nachhinein das große drückt sie
und irgendwann zum 20 seine frau birgit
und ich muss es
kopiert und ohne und ich nahezu der lift
oder
pc schmackhaft
er hat mit
restwasser sich
ad hoc mainka dies nicht sondern
interessante sie zieht also interessante
geschäft kann ich dank das ist ein
der korpus der karabag
billig dividiert sie will das ist aber
nicht immer so dass spitzbübisches
lachen und das quält und dann ist der
ball
textarbeit
und vietnam reagiert als ich trinke ich
bin sehr stinkt oscommerce das ist
die idee hinter
dem komitee keine juden nicht
widerrechtlich sehr lustiger
showerhead sofort alle anbieter
[Musik]
und wenn ich draußen
sitzen versteckt
ich hatte sofort die september nicht in
new york mein name ist internationale
stadt ein internationaler kanton sich
irgendwo wieder sagten dort auf der
kantonsrat kuriert und ich bin der
staatskanzleien der plan mit polizei
erhöhten ja und dass eine immer klappt
und wir haben riesige angst gewichen
[Musik]
ich bin faul haben
und da bin ich dann sofort uwe und
schlimmstes links monika unter wie ich
vor getötet sie liebte plugin
[Musik]
dem boden mit ganz viel blut so übrigen
an tier und
mini kollegin runden tisch hätten
ich stehe auch pedale wenn wir sterben
dalí
sich gegenüber stufen und viele sogar
die fenster fleckeby die hof gestanden
und hat das fan struktur
und hat eine erste mal in ruhe gesorgt
und das einerseits
still sind querbeet pflege alles
umgestoßen menschen im mini kolleginnen
und kollegen am boden und hat einen
makel betrug das war wenige meter vor
mir gestanden ist die fertigung
polizei gestanden ist
sind verteidigers polizist
die hätten gemacht k und glüht zu
versenken da sofort auf den zweiten
blick sehe dass es kein polizist ist
das ist es rolle spielt sie das heißt
der
rolle gespielt vor dem ohne gemacht wo
ist die mafia und mehr als thema für ihn
dass er dir durchs radio geknurrt
munition des kommissariats umzubringen
und so hat man das attentat sie laufen
ich bin unter den tisch und
das gefühl kann wenigstens bis der
nachricht gestützt dass er wenig raxit
und grimma die reihen in schutz
wien
nach links der stoff wurde am hals oder
schufen dass dann dort sammelte vor mir
gesehen
[Musik]
wir haben trikot vor der schule
und ich kann eigentlich mit ballack und
kantonsrat
und
probierte gemeint night train sicher
nicht mikrosievert abstimmungen und
alles aber ich könnte sich besonders
moment sie mit dem schiff hayek war
überzogen
und ehre darf auch zeiten mit dem
debakel
die puppe die
schulkarriere liebenswerter mensch sehr
viel freude
hat viel und mit denen hat
viele sachen gemeinsam machen und ja
der ist viel frisst sie haben noch viele
andere sachen gemacht hat aber ich
glaube für kindisch am schönsten wenn
das gefühl es erhält nur fiktiv ist
nichts weil man muss den folgenden
spielen
aber wenn ich sofort
via usb
slot 2 wurde eigentlich und ja gar kein
entwickler
xi'an
[Musik]
jede einzelne shows zählt ihre
militärmacht ich habe bis jetzt muss
magazin leer sie und hat dank dänisches
fertig
und das magazin gewechselt und das ist
der erste gedanke juni küster das ist
ernst das ist völlig wir sind dauernd
nur wahnsinnige sachen der oder hot fuzz
einer sie technisch auf dem frühesten
ist einfach wer jetzt gelegenheit
ergriffen habe mich getraut also liege
ich wieder zurückkommen boden zu meinen
kolleginnen und war die serie ist
wählerisch
auf die schauer gestiegen zum teil und
head grade rufus aber geschossen also
von dem her für mich nicht wie ich
wird
[Musik]
ich habe im saal bin der
kantonsratssitzung eigentlich ein gefühl
das sägen traum ich sehe gerne schlafen
und träume bis unter nicht verwandten 3
und vw aber leider ist dann nicht
besonders ist
ein moment den schuss gespürt hat
dominique potteau
wohin der küste ich muss doch ob ich
zurückkehre
der einzige moment
feststand tankt das ist sie
erwarte jetzt führungsstärke wie mini
mutter will mich immer dasselbe mit
einer 40
wolfsburger bin ich geschützt und haben
dann auch der kopf hinter michael
steinsträter minimal und dem moment ist
etwas in die cloud also standort als er
mich sehr bewegend roman the truth
großer und dann hat es mich an der hand
verletzt
die höhere
normalen arbeitstag sie bis zu dem punkt
wo der
kommandant kantonspolizei mir auch
gewitter hat und die scharia ist ein
übel sich irgendwo so einen überblick in
der luft gegangen er dachte er sich die
bischöfe unglücke schon zu dem zeitpunkt
aber hat er schnell merkt aufgrund vom
tonfall vor ihm das ist ja ich hatte
eine das büro der stadtpolizei
überkonsum colin platz und somit sehr
noch vom regierungsgebäude und habe
nicht eine minimale ausgerichtet
übersprungen über den 1 platz bitte
holen ruhig denn bloß systems telefon
gange dass wir auch interventionen von
den schießereien regierung deutlich dass
fahrkarten die ziehen wir wissen dass
mit monika angegangen haben machen sie
schlachtet sie in burg für gegeben
was
ok stocken gekommen
abbruch die verfügen
[Musik]
vielmehr
sind
die
hasserfüllt die stimme
ich mag mich nicht erinnern jemals ein
stinker so hasserfüllt und
auch später im schlaf am netz verfolgt
sondern sie bestimmen
ich habe dann einfach überkauft ja
hoffentlich trifft und bin eine frau
unter das bunte woche und habe ich
versucht hinter dem koffer zu stecken
mit 37 zum sterben
[Musik]
erst geht es bei buch vorkommen jetzige
marken geklemmt und
hatte kunde kann ich eigentlich nur
sagen jetzt genauso wie der verliebtheit
phase auch schon wieder abschied nicht
von hand
dann hätte weiter geschossen
und den honig größtes magazin mit der
lehr und denn alle schritt gehört wo sie
nicht sie sind
und den hetzen
knallte
im ersten gedanken handgranate
jetzt heute krank aprilia kommt man
am schluss
anhört wie sturm quer apotheke und
dennis stolle schuss und deniz mir quasi
als hätte sich selber um braucht und es
ist mit axel
schuster mit dem stumpfen mit der waffe
lang soldat
sich sander versüßt mit der waffe vom
offizier mit der waffe von der wirkliche
ehre
[Musik]
die
der männer saugen und dass ich es bis
ins endspiel
und
der geschmack von blut und vor der bombe
platze hätte dass ich hinten aus
durchmachen biden und ex mann und ich
denke jetzt gerade
hat und dass ich nur schlimm sie
auf dem markt dürfen also schon ein
starker husten
muskel- und im saale in der sauberen
also hätte nur prompt auf den punkt der
seite er auch
das ist einfach dort aus ging
und darum kann man ruhig der übeltäter
hatte und ich da wieder weggehen oder
wie es der plötzlich völlig
intervention seien haltlos ja nicht
wirklich die lage im griff und nicht wie
sauber oder dritte wie die klage
[Musik]
so schnell ist ein richtiges gebäude ist
als starke häuser unmittelbar vor der
stärker bevor er minister kliniken die
da nicht den geschmack kontakt kamen
vorgesetzte eigentlich für deine die
informationen schlüsselinformationen für
mich steckt achtung hätten
polizeiuniformen
klopft
verletzt
tote
das ist völlig unübersichtlich und noch
nicht wirklich klar ob sich
die jungs
spielten zum tanz
dies habe gemacht die unbekannten
was wir zu dem zeitpunkt monique küste
wir sind nicht die ersten polizisten
sind
[Musik]
der mini future der situation auf dem
markt so
was gut möglich dass ich eine kamera die
chance sein und mit dem
noch ist der kunden zu identifizieren
kann
[Musik]
realisiertes krieg muss mit dem jetzt
auch für sein baby etwas wie
die ursache
auf dem konto
ich sehe ich wirklich leid
[Applaus]
es gibt ein filmriss primär noch ein
pistolenschuss
will wenn ich wieder zu mehr habe ja
nichts merke dass ich wieder zu mir
komme
bin ich total gangkofen zu mindern und
den bin janko und
hat seit rolf es ist vorbei und hätte
kein banker
dann zeigt er das bewusstlos
denn die nächste
11 rasch stars wie der dekabank dankt er
deshalb bewusstlos
und dann bin ich aus dem saal oder gar
nicht gewusst dass händen mehr zwölf
tote sind oder dritte mit dem täter
[Musik]
der stadtteil ist
vom talmud xii
was ich mit meiner frau ist wo ich mich
nicht wehren konnten wir sie gern und
ich habe ein paar das eine könne was
wirklich passiert ist
japan besitzt nichts sagen und ja der
kulisse
wurde
vermutlich
leider und das sind so momente
[Musik]
hände möglich polizei vor ort gibt es
aber noch keine entwarnung
polizeiautos husumer fahrrad dabei die
technischen systeme zeigen
kontakt links
und
witzige bei enercon und jetzt plötzlich
heiser achtung handgranate
[Musik]
die hand nicht gesehen wenn ich einfach
für beziehen der tatsachen angelangt da
und kann hat das
verfahren umgestellt
die 21 jährige im falle einer verletzung
will ich keine medizinische hilfe werde
keine bezahlen und habe keine
versicherung
sowie stand und wo sind die anderen
ja jetzt ist es gerade so dass regierung
die innere und schwer zugänglich sind
so zu reden nach dem motto was muss ich
mir vorstelle dass schon ein riesiger
schock fenster plötzlich so trifft und
trifft und glied singt einfach
weggerannt und mehr weißen moment monika
worden ich weiß momentan ist dringend
aus dem zehn euro seien
ungefährlich angesehen haben wir
dringend müssen entschluss finde so ja
jetzt ist es so dass im moment ein
polizist am ufer
und vermutlich informationen gibt
es im kantonsratssaal in zug wo sie
offenbar das attentat ereignet hat
aber die laufende informationen die
politik hätte ich noch aus erklärt
ganze pizza abzeichnet
[Musik]
achtung ein zweiter täter eine
bestehende wiederhole riether 8 und
wollte tat
gestanden
also wir haben vielleicht nur zwei kufen
doch
die hölle los
und dann sehen wir denn die schnelle
verschiebung besonders lachen vergangen
und ethischen ohrenschmalz wechseln das
heißt die möglichkeit das nie drei
personen direktor der kölner stellen
offen da habe ich zwei
grad
und den handel mit co2 also mini
unterlagert sein ruhm und haben ist
weit hainbuchen dazu das ist ein aber
die gangl schmerzen so groß wurde sind
die der hand und führte taten hatte das
als ziel hat das leben und bin den usa
und das ist wirklich ein traum bleibt
sie
[Musik]
das freut uns diese stücke
die berichtssaison deutschen person
gesehen wo besonders von dem zeitpunkt
praktisch
jedes gebäude im polizeijargon sünkels
sie alles gut
danke
jungs wir glauben
sind kollegen auf mich zu erholen und da
sitzt diese kolleg schwer verletzt als
helfer und ich hatte
schnell gesehen sehr verschlossen sich k
s
schwer verletzt und kam mit
den stuhl uhr und in den mit dem stuhl
ist für autos nicht stark therapie
oftmals stuhl am kopf
und im gesicht über dem kopf
1 durch und
meine fraktionskollegen manuela weichelt
ist nah bin gestand das ist nur logisch
august frankreichs bildlichkeit
trotz eine schwere verletzung ist voll
ansprechbar sie
einem auch eine tante und technologie
pfarrer mobile kulturen
und 10 im kantonsspital
aarau und t shirt sind hofen notfall
durch standen parat
die hände mit dem stuhl des schulischen
und bikini zum streit und
durchweg ja
die sind sehr schwer das ist ja
wahnsinnig versorgt hatte ihnen den
kleinen
medizinische unterstützung
für mieten spitze norden das hätte mir
braucht und tim
ratsmitglieder den schnellgang bis die
medizinische unterstützung oder taxis
[Musik]
hatte noch leichter gemacht ich habe
auch sehr viel anspruchsvoller empfunden
als
das
mögliche und
natürlich sogleich tomasson nehmen und
diese reaktion nicht mickrig und
immer ärger was können sie zur zahl der
opfer haben von 14 toten ist die rede
darunter auch regierungsseite können sie
das bestätigen
die polizei bestätigt dass er sich
tatsächlich um 14 opfer handelt noch ist
nicht klar ob regierungsräte darum das
sind derzeit schweren viele gerichte
jeden zug herum
ich weiß es nicht die polizei gibt es
derzeit nicht bekannt
der medienkongress erste international
bekannt hat die zeit denn schon indizien
die die täterschaft
und geht von einem einzeltäter aus angst
sich offenbar um einen schweizer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das team
zum bestand der amokläufer haben seinem
gegner der schweizer an seine pflichten
der mann habe
ein zusammen haben
vielleicht ja auch für die wahnsinnstat
könnte der umstand sein dass das zuger
obergericht diese woche einige
beschwerden abgewiesen haben der täter
hatte mit diesen beschwerden mehreren
bekannten zu bei amtsträgern missbräuche
ihrer stellung vorgeworfen die schau die
die bilanz 14 mitglieder von regierung
und parlament wenig getötet andere
werden verletzt einige von ihnen schwer
[Musik]
das
bringt ihnen kommen und einfach drauflos
gerechnet ab sucht und einfach etwas
drama wende bewirkt die erste sanitäter
es geht wie mir den vergangen zwei
hinter mir send tod und der high
performance es scheint ich hab's aber
nur gestreift und
center hat ausschusses zu ihnen und den
ärzten
des st foto verlag sieht sie das ist
dominant wirbel und hat nun fünf
klinische und lesen können müssen es ist
unvorstellbar brauchen
ich weiß nicht warum diesmal habe so
bleibt für video entstanden
ich bin der regionaldekane konferenz see
und am morgen plötzlich ist mexikos ist
es passiert in zug und der
generalvikar zeit alfredo ich glaub die
fertigung und den habe ich mich sofort
in dieser hot summer packt und der
aufzug fahren sie mit
herzklopfen sri lanka und dann bin ich
in den start gegangen und zwar ins ins
gebäude vor der kantonalbank wird ist
eigentlich alles zusammen klopfen und es
ist wirklich ein risiko genannt wird
nachdem das ganze gebäude das in einer
sicherlich ist dann sehr schnell
umgangen
verletzt und frauen berichtet will die
angehörigen natürlich das bedürfnis kaum
möglich schnell zwischen ich mich sagte
die mutter mit rührte ist unter den
toten oder nee das ist ein enormer druck
die familie natürlich logisch wie sofort
zurück machten das haben wir dann
einigermaßen uv oder die hotline sorge
teilen
ich habe den morgen und
das radio
telefon und nicht da bin ich koche und
dann ist er froh
kontrons
rom geschossen worden und tut meine
schulter ist für roxy und hätte nach
glück dass man ja etwas erinnerungen
gibt es auch eine anlaufstelle für
angehörige
ja das gebäude der zuger kantonalbank
das gerade neben dem regierungsgebäude
steht das wurde sofort nach dem vorfall
geschlossen dort wurde die
einsatzzentrale eingerichtet und dorthin
können sich auch angehörige wenden die
hier vor ort erscheinen und nach dem
schicksal ihrer angehörigen fragen sie
werden dann in das gebäude geleitet und
werden dort auch psychologisch betreut
um im ostergarten
kreisverkehr die dissidenten informiert
wurden und die die kantonalbank die
zweite stück besitzen groß rum wo sich
die treffen sind und das criminal
dann bin ich die düffel und
langsam langsam sind dann
sieht man ein genie griffen alle
gewartet und gewartet und dann hätten
wir das lied von kontrons roxy wo man
auf it und irgendwie muss ich sagen wir
doch endlich
los wieso sind jetzt rund und der
querschnitte und
und in ercis
wo die zig sie mit belegt und es bitte
mit denen in der zeit liegt er muss den
hanseatischen weg gewählt und
mit bereit wo angekündigt
die damalige land schrieb ich sie daran
es sind eigentlich da
relativ vorgehen ram zeigen mit dem
normalen schrieb blog bremer denn je
zurück bezahlt und sind eine frau tötete
person zunächst
und
komfortabler versorgen sie versucht ein
system in das zimmer im griff
das körperlich und
mit geklappt hat
beim heutigen amok anschlag auf das
regierungsgebäude sind r peter bossert
regierungsrat er schon baxmann
regierungsrat und frau regierungsrätin
monika mutter zu tode gekommen auf der
seite des parlamentes beklagen wir den
code des kantonsrats präsidenten herbert
arndt
des kantonsrats beverly martin
geräten er kann
heimgartner dollar
bieten eric
nussbaumer kurz
nußbaum ruf
und wie ist
die 13 los gehe
also ablösefrei
sind verstummt die sind
jede idee fliegt
oder herr krug wasser machen
und wenn ich dies auch fest dass durch
personal wie es ruhig kommen
ich nehme die gelegenheit wahr allen
angehörigen
das tief empfundenes beileid
der rest regierung auszusprechen
ja
und dann
einfach gar nichts gefühlt irgendwie
und
zurückfahren und
und wenn ja wenn ich schwach dürfen und
die tour ich noch richtig
realisieren
was passiert ist genau
und ja die verstoßen hat
[Musik]
ich teile diesen
vorstellungen
mit
den betroffenen
mit den angehörigen
und die haben es wirklich bewegt das ist
schon noch nicht ein ich hab nichts
geschenkt der zuckerpreis lobby einzel
was hätte
ich habe das nicht kreativ auf den
deckel der mode zu
[Musik]
hallo
ja gott sei dank
ich will dir alles gute
für dich nur dann
okay
ist er bis das
ist
jetzt sieht es daran
mit energie vom parlamentsgebäude hat
polizist auto gefunden wo offenbar an
armutsgrenze die waffe kam
bezüglich um dort motiv
einen bekennerbrief band toto runde
er ist betitelt mit tag des zornes für
die zukunft er schreibt darin dass der
tag des todes für die zugemacht für
heute stattgefunden habe er sagt dass er
die zyklus titz viele verfahren
verschleppt verdeckt habe es geht darum
dass er die verschiedene chauffeure der
zugelangt verkehrsbetriebe des
alkoholkonsums bezichtigte er hat
entsprechende klagen deponiert und wenn
es überall abgeblitzt und das wird wohl
der grund sein weshalb zu dieser markt
hat gegangen ist
[Musik]
daher kann ich mit dem vorfall sagen
michael
telefoniert haben abgemacht dass ich auf
wenn ich
im radio
froh dass sich zu treffen und dann ist
natürlich kirche roms volks und oswald
und 90 stände treffen
einfach ganz wichtiger gemacht
[Musik]
denn
sind t
online.de
[Musik]
lisa c die medien stoff von ab
so schnell
kann ein zuschuss zu oft ja
immer neues gibt's
die heizkreise und zwar um wo im
kantonsrat
als würze kaiser polizei
erschoss und toyo ito zentrum k und ich
auch wirklich zentrum ist das im prinzip
auf mich
zukommt und asyl im rechten aber auch
honig motto wo sind die waffe wo eine
seite wo es ist gut wenn die waffen
upgrades sind könner technische dienste
sind auf das
sichtlich erlischt wird gesehen dass
dann tatsächlich so gemacht inszeniert
and und ist jetzt eigentlich zeigt
trainierte video grenzt
einzig josef k aber wenn sie so gesehen
wird dann muss ich weg bin war das so im
raum fertig
verhältnismäßig sie also fordern ob er
jede kasse muss also wie ich persönlich
angegriffen wurde waren wir so eine
situation wie ist denke ich ich arbeite
mich aus mittel und drum heimat aber
noch die professionelle truppe der bak
und die wie trifft zugezogen dpa
taktisch richtig und vor allem
verhältnismäßig und rechtlich korrekt
handelt
ich mache jetzt einfach wo willst du mit
mir entschädigung muss zählt
ja wieso denn
ihr name ist das letzte haben damit nun
der bundesrat stimmt
ja wie der typ in zug art
und ich mache fertig man muss mal mit
schlafsäcken
h
[Musik]
plate
es ist super
links
[Musik]
super
organisiert und durch
dagmar mosch ich habe keine mitwisser
und habe ganz alleine
eine schnelle identifizierung
bekommst ich würde mir ein ich den knall
vivesco valley wichtig aus der antike
und
somit wird man sagen so gut bürger oder
irgendwas im stück wunder
staatliches unternehmen beschäftigt und
dann ist es normal seien
falsch geschrieben
[Musik]
ja
okay wir sind in 20 minuten
einen tag nach dem scheren kann
bekommt leider
ist mit seinem vorstoß sie würden mit
dem beruf gewählt
also wie usain
bolt
kleine kriminelle
verstoß gegen das waffengesetz dann hat
mich bedroht
und
genau das ist mir was genau das schießt
mir aus dem blut dass man sowie die
ottonen kommunizieren
kann ihr wort charakter attentat
ich bin eigentlich glücklich sie
dass ich wüsste dass sich der attentate
selber umgebracht hat weil ich überzeugt
bin waren als ich nicht unbeachtet
mit einer wenig
für die zuger justiz ist der täter kein
unbeschriebenes blatt er wurde
1970 bereits durch das strafgericht hier
in zug verteilt wegen diversen
vermögensdelikten wegen unzucht mit
kindern öffentlichen unzüchtigen
handlungen
urkundenfälschung und
straßenverkehrsdelikten
er wurde damals zu 18 monaten
freiheitsentzug verurteilt aber
stattdessen in eine
arbeitserziehungsanstalt eingewiesen
es mangelt es super gemacht sid wir
kriegen alles die sitte zusammenklappt
dass mir das wirklich nie exakt wie sehr
muss sie hat bin ich heilfroh dass man
das nächste
frage ich mich
warum geben sowie die frage warum
erst jetzt
[Musik]
box abstellen oder
doch lieber raus
[Musik]
gewerbeflächen der ruf besitzen
gar nicht macht
[Musik]
geschickt was erwartet sie also von
großstadt
ja seid natürlich seitigen bericht mit
der regierung verwaltungsteil irgendwo
längste sender
unterhemd oder e-mails oder diskret ein
bravo de vita und visa card und
drohten wieder troicki und dezember
johannes reagieren
sind
ich orte
es geht einzige politische frage wo
gestellt wurde nicht nur das attentat ab
sie für sicherheitsmaßnahmen das ist ein
waffengesetzgebung war einfach toll es
ist verantwortungslos
botschafter bedürfe lindner
begriffen pump actions
4007 moment nicht so schnell
64 81 07
konnte bern
universums
214 00 32
er wurde konnte und syrien
206 auch kein waffenschein notwendig zum
beispiel die pump action die henry ford
kaufte hätte für kai waffenerwerbsschein
braucht
es sie kann registers sie schwiegen denn
immer also nicht im register von konten
oder darauf verkauft hat mit den
registern kommt und sören gonther im
moment geschweige denn hand hätte kommt
und zu von dem können der fahrer die
wende konnte und zu erfahren hatte dass
die als so einen lauf verpasst da hat
jeder polizist in mexiko der fall hatte
thalia longo getötet wenn man so eine
situation hände um gewisse
ruhe kommt von der person sowie
natürlich die elegischen checken oder
aber als sie den fachbereichen wie nyt
küste
der rechten seite schossen
b92
als 44 2
legaler wurde
1960 im fachhandel hinzu
ich frage mich das paradies für freaks
nicht
getötet sondern um die es in der hand
hält
schuster verwies aber und trotzdem rasch
illegal wie sie zu bewaffnen schreibe
ich einen anderen kanton st
ich hatte
zuständige behörde der zuständigen
polizei kann ich keinen vorwurf machen
also ich wüsste nicht was er tun was sie
hatte trainer anders machen aufgrund von
der damaligen gesetzeslage aufgrund von
der damaligen situation
es ist ja auch nur ein andere kritik
geäußert wurde
mit ins weniger ernst
und kann man sich einfach sagen das ist
humbug ich meine sogar ein regierungsrat
hat ihnen kann ich wählen kann
grund ein querulant und linz in
regierungsrot über das ist
und der chef vom öffentlichen verkehr
mit dem er wurde zeit habe ich mit der
materie konflikt daher den glüh mal
heiter mit dem krebs wenn ich mich
einfach zu bedienen oder sehr steht
sprach wenn ich versuche das leck war es
die untersuchung resultat sind dann
interessiert das eigentlich nicht will
eintracht mit dem was er geschrieben
andere interessiert ihn nicht das ist so
einfach komplett rechthaberisch und wenn
er über niedrig gibt dann ist das sind
und dass er sich in der letzten woche
roland ihnen bombe verwandelt dass das
hat man könne müsse
ja hallo
ja
das kann ich gar nicht mehr
wo es okay
danke
willst du
sonst
gar nicht merkt
[Musik]
wie albini
keine frage das ist auch der umgang ist
es
dann so wie schwefel
sofern das überhaupt
rockbands das richtig gemacht
berichte dass er sowas machen
sind wichtig der jungen mannschaft sagte
sie
nachdem sie
vielleicht noch früher für die sander
kritik
ich habe alles was im zusammenhang mit
dem attentat böse das andere kommen ist
es auch nicht
korrekt
es gibt nicht auf sie
und dann trotzdem der nötige abstand
bewahrt
gut gemacht
vor dem club
[Musik]
liefert so eine mutter
ich weiß morgen als er seinen sohn
michael klante und herren oder
gottesdienst redet und was man für
zeichen setzen
und
handwerk moment für harry potter
immer abfährt und
das ist unsere ausgangslage behandelt
gar nicht vom opfer und tötet sondern
einfach vor den bug stolper sind zum
thema big vor dem ersten oktober und das
telefon über who und der mtv
einheit aus geistlichkeit weil die 15a
zünder und ruhr gottesdienst von sankt
michael sich die nacht habe ich nicht
viel gelaufen das hat mich so
beschäftigen
[Musik]
er stellt der verstorbene und das licht
von gott
hier versteht
übergab
gott fortschritte waren wir jetzt sind
die barmherzigkeit zielvorgabe gezeigt
dass es nicht unsere sache
wenn wir glauben dass gott denn schon
weiß was auch jetzt wenn der wähler
wieder gut und das wissen mehr über
nicht und hatten wir können es nicht
wissen und soll es auch eine solotour
teile also
ist das wirklich es liegt vor gott wo
aldi nord
derby sieg und trug schwarzes in der
sakristei
gretel mit reichlich ein dass die 15
tracks wird sei mit absender und sie
sind den rektor und ja und bei den
hybrid- und
fantasy hoffen kann und dennoch nichts
um ruby ruby mine eigentlichen zur küste
wir sind da nicht solche strafen und
einfach zeitlos
ich hatte ja das können obwohl ziert das
dass das schwierig ist es schwierig ist
aber
von mir von ihm glaube habe das gericht
kann er ganz
los los denn gerade da
posiert vor gott
daten buch das ganz besonders
und
jetzt
es schließe das hat mich persönlich
punkt wenn er verurteilt
und das steht mir jetzt gegenüber
verstorben er einfach dazu
ich war damals so fortgeschrieben bitte
macht das nützt das verletzte mimik fühl
und maschine also ganz viel vorhanden
[Musik]
rexroth bissig und
xhaka von thierry wirklich für nicht
wer mir die er von 50 hertz halten
und dein zimmer eigentlich außer garner
und sind sogar ohne zu wissen was jetzt
machen
[Musik]
junghanns nicht wüst
rossmann und einfach nur kurz währen
sünden an der osterkerze
kerzen zum zeichen dafür dass unsere
verstorbenen im licht gottes sind
und auch in unseren herzen
peter rost
antreten
dorli heimgarten
ich habe gespürt dass ein wahnsinn
spanisch wo man ist
ich war schwer kocht dass die 50 jetzt
nicht als und das obwohl ich die
theologische hintergedanken so
verstanden da ich denke man tun um einen
stehtisch gibt es nur noch einrichten
das ist gott
denn honeycomb kurt koch neben ihm saß
an ihrem zug für schritt gibt doch die
kerze mehr
wir müssen abschied nehmen von 14
menschen die
aus ihrem leben und aus unserem
lebenskreis gerissen worden sind er muss
ganz ehrlich sagen
das hat dort gelten darf nicht zu
überzeugen das hat nehmen können
verstauen und ich habe mir vorgenommen
wenn das wirklich so war glaube ich war
das mittel rundgang und da sagt man eben
davon erfolgt
diese große sünde zu vergeben
und eine kerze auch
dafür anzuzünden ich spüre es ist zu
früh aber
ich übergebe eine kerze dem regional
bekannt dir lieber alfred und du wirst
in deinem pastoralreisen herzen spüren
wann es möglich ist
toni garrn gefühlt ja jetzt hat ja
wahnsinn sub pop
also
aufgabe
muss man lösen und
daher nicht wirklich
gut verteilen kann dass das schon gut
wird
[Musik]
nach etlichen kreierten groß sind die
schäden die mit rasse und hans blossey
wie's kommt der bischof laufen und
inspektionen der bischof ganz ganz
herzlichen dank aber zur antwort
aber normal laut sich viele melodien und
das könnt ihr euch vorstellen dass die
erhöhten eigentlich mehr haben
wir haben das gefühl dass man den
menschen
warten aber denkt also nahe also der
jahrestag dagott sich nett und darum ein
modell ein anderes datum gesucht mit dem
allerseelentag wo mehr da für alle
verstorbenen
[Musik]
sind sie in die b
10 an
schauen wir doch schon wieder noch
wahnsinnig toll
wochen später
zur stelle und sonstige machen
sich das
psychologen ad hoc vom careteam der
gesprochen zurückzieht und das nie
gemacht
sie hat
es mir so war
ich weiß es nicht
ich
sie mit reebok
drei kilo an der belastung
ist aber
weil sie aber doch langsam gefüllt mit
einer baby bild liegt und dann noch die
schönen erinnerung und das haben wir
alle
models mit manchen wo man lebt oder 100
oder auto ist ja egal
es trennt sie dann das biz ausgerichtet
es bringt doch nicht sind alle tot
mir geht es nicht um die tote
mir gott zum die
rede hilft
einen sprung stürzt da muss er sowieso
schon so spät dass ich doch jetzt ein
blöd dafür gleich wieso
honig die 70 gange tina
schaudt
sie stehen ja entscheiden
ich bin
gut macht
liga
das trauma
anderes
laptop groß
[Musik]
und es gibt schädigungen und eschwege
die blieben
red aufgehübschte
fb
häufig nach am morgen aufgestanden
versucht zu machen hanna butterhof
nutzung für sein gebot abgeschnitten hat
ein abo nötig ist dass ich wähle morgen
esse ich total schwierigkeit terminen
überhaupt die zarten
basilika ist den versucht wieder zur
auto
aber
kein einziger satz fehlerfrei
geschrieben
dass ich bin ich mitgegangen
ich habe es am sonntag nicht reden über
der fall geht das einfach nicht das
nicht fertig brachte
es ist
schwierig sie kann vielleicht auch nicht
will ritter
und
komisch ist nur fünfter
[Musik]
wenn ich wieder tramfahrer wie und der
krieg fenster im rahmen einer
krankheit also besonders trip fenster
zuletzt etwas
erinnert und hatten so schnell wieder
gemerkt dass ich vom herrschte
entspannte dass ich wir sind jetzt nicht
im kanton zug
ein
[Musik]
der mensch ist ja eigentlich ausgang für
geboten
dass er sich sicher fühlt
und dass wir darum eigentlich im besten
fall aber das grundvertrauen hat
und sobald das wegfall als auch e mails
als reinste sie oder nicht
dann voll der mensch zum vertrauen
vertrauen ist aber möglich gewesen
vertrauen jeden gewählten religion
und fühlt sich vorstellen unsicher und
dann stand blätter und sie fertig werden
[Musik]
hallo
wir brauchen hilfe
er bedrohte mit einer waffe
er hat nie druck
im kanton st foto posiert ist
ganz ganz wichtig finde ich
doof mit dem 1
wie sie diese letztlich
war nimmt
es
medizinisch für leipzig ist in der mitte
geliebte und die silos tennisplätze
entschuldigung für die schneeball
kellogg co
komme gern
[Musik]
es gibt mit
demütigendes obhut demütigendes wie
immer man spur schwerst traumatisiert
ist
sage
du bist wie die
djs gibt kreis goslar
es geht nur in russland das alter ist
definitiv
natürlich zwei jahre nicht trainer
schaffte will ich an
meinem
beruf schaffen es einfach nicht mehr
möglich
an der kraft einer kag viel
und so habe ich dann einfach messe mich
so schnell zurück macht
hdmi büro gemacht und
administratives
aber schmerzen habe ich zum teil hüttner
muss zum teil heute noch je nach
witterungslage medikamenten gegen
schmerzen
aber
die schmerzen ertragen nur gut
[Musik]
außer viel an sich lassen können
vorstellen dass
- xii das ist auch ein teil von ihnen
verarbeitet sie wohl nicht es als ob ich
meine sofort taxi oder geschwärzt und
teil dieses und so ich bezahle der stadt
eingegangen
und ich glaube
hat sehr stieg sie das mini belegen der
platzwechsel richtig sich dass die
rallye
völlig durch schoss sie sind und ich
bitte ihn so
auf stocker hat das leere
[Musik]
gummi hier sind und eine längs über
mehere und ich habe getroffen
und den han ja auch mit hörgerät und pcs
mit blumen als organisator
david
merlini sohn von einem opfer
trug das logo mit
dem schuss ins linke ohr bitte tut
das ist das plätze da
das schlimmste es
[Musik]
ich weise kann mit der prepaid wortes in
karger
aber könnte nicht sagen mit wenn das das
gesicht
ich bin sehr interessiert
mich das
jetzt
schwierig sie irgendwie die schritte
jetzt machen aber
ich werde den weg und wir jetzt gesehen
wie die verarbeitung für das ganze
fassen und ortsnahe wissen
[Musik]
dann können auch wir verbundenheit
mit dem quatsch das
ist in zukunft unseren twitter schaffen
und
aus mehreren 20 jahren jetzt schon
vorhand wirkt vieles
wieder ruhe wenn er mit dieter
stolze sowie mit dafür
ihre meist viel wissen eigentlich auch
hinten der gute ausbildung
die
zielsetzung hand brach co-trainer
verfolgen und dann mache ich das gefühl
da hilft es aber so die unterstützung
die wir von irgendwo östlich
geht
[Musik]
bis das nicht eigentlich immer perfekt
für was für und der mehr menschen fähig
sind das ist für mich eigentlich
unbegreiflich
aber
es ist irgendwie zu unserer hand
[Musik]
und darum
haben wir einfach für das attentat durch
erwartet oder anderer dankt sondern
überhaupt
für all die menschen wo nicht anders zu
helfen als einfach mit wald
wenig medikamente ganz am anfang mal zum
und baurecht zu können schlafen ich habe
müsse zum alkohol greifen
ich habe auch meine freundinnen wichtig
für ganz fest stützend mit mit
partner
mit zucker bevölkerung und phänomenal
hin wenn man dann wieder denke es gibt
ja so viele ton ist rau bleibt wird das
ganze land bewältigen
theresa luxuskarossen
zuger bevölkerung kein schweizer
bevölkerung
ich habe mich wahnsinnig breit kühlt
[Musik]
gott sei dank
dagegen aber
noch nicht ganz raus
ja ja
ich das
15 millimeter strom
günstiger verrückte das
schicksal gottes tempel sagen diese
intern aber der stadt aachen
internet
genau
[Musik]
ich meine es fragt wieso er sich
überrascht über
man salat zu gute
der und irgend straße schlug
das war nett wenn der
herrgott einfach 1000 so um bestraft
wird
irgendwoher
strafe
natürlich besonders stark ist eine
situation dass eine partnerschaft
bedeutet also in dem moment hat
individuelle reise
und mehr hand den anderthalb jahre nach
dem attentat karotten und bananen
ananas gemacht juli
der belebende quadrant als und zeigen
sie sollten aktiv erarbeitet
und sind allemal
[Musik]
sie ist natürlich heftig schiffes
hat teil härter gemacht auf böse sachen
seiner vielleicht gewisse sachen
abgestumpft aber zum teil ist dünnhäutig
geworden
vor allem nachts wien geschrieben
und ganz vergessen dort man das nie
[Musik]
was mich sehr
betroffen macht das hätte so viel sagen
was ich wirklich
engagierte der kanton für swift und die
sind jedes
wort unseren kunden
[Musik]